French president Emmanuel macron was
welcomed by Democratic Republic of
Congo's president Felix chiseketti in
the capital Kinshasa
but not everybody in Congo is happy
about it
[Music]
activists have demonstrated against the
visit in Goma and Kinshasa
we don't want president Macau in our
country because he's financing the
Rwandan government in order to kill our
people
blame France for supporting neighboring
Rwanda that's widely understood to back
the M23 armed group in eastern Congo
more than half a million people have
fled their homes as its Fighters have
advanced in the last year they're
accused of massacring dozens of
civilians they carry Rwandan Army
equipment which the protesters say is
paid for by Franz Rwanda denies backing
the group
in Kinshasa macron said all sides in the
conflict had agreed to a ceasefire none
of the previous ceasefire declarations
in recent months have worked the
Democratic Republic of Congo must not be
The Spoils of War the pillaging of the
Democratic Republic of Congo must stop
no losing no balkanization no war
also included stops in Republic of Congo
Angola and Gabon he started his tour
saying the era of French interference in
Africa was over this discourse that
French Nook organism is over well it has
been there for at least the last five
decades but the reality is here because
uh the French government is still
backing uh unpopular I would say even
despotic regimes that are opposed by
their populations
macron promised about 36 million dollars
for those forced from their homes and in
Angola he offered a loan of about 150
million dollars for what he called
climate resilience but critics say
that's a fraction of what France earns
from African oil and other natural
resources Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera